fighting together to defend something we love.
Their nightmare is songs
You must know you cannot win
That's impressive.
every hunting rifle, every knife
every round of ammunition in the village of.
Show them mercy.
The time has come
for all that you love.
You stand between us and annihilation.
Welcome back, everyone.
It's Charlie.
This will be my Rebel Moon two trailer video.
They released some footage from part two,
and they're kind of doing it like dune.
Like dune. Part one, Part two.
Even though it's like the first movie.
The second movie, they'll do more movies
if the first two are successful.
there's a bunch going on here.
So if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
Netflix clearly wants to make this
their next real big franchise.
Like their prequels, they're working on their tie
in books, They were also supposed to be
making a Rebel Moon video game,
but it might have canceled that.
I planned to do a couple more videos for the movie,
but there's so much stuff happening right now
that I'll just try to, like,
cram it all into a couple of different videos.
Careful for spoilers from Rebel Moon Part one
If you haven't seen that first movie yet
in Big reminder to There is meant to be a director's
cut like they went
full Snyder cut part of me thinks that Netflix
kind of planned it this way, though.
Like we'll release the short one
first to build demand for the Snyder cut of Rebel Moon.
Then we'll release the Snyder cut.
It'll be way more popular.
Zack Snyder said it's almost like 4 hours long.
So they cut it way, way down for like this
regular theatrical version of the cut.
And I think a lot of the complaints against the movie,
like a lot of the criticisms
are just due
to the fact that they cut out so much from the movie.
in most of the stuff to hit the cutting room
floor was the character work.
So there's like a lot of universe building
that's going on during this.
Like a lot of world building.
It all seems like really cool mythology
that they're setting up.
but I think when the director's cut
comes out for part one,
the movie will just wind up being way, way better.
The same way that the Justice League
Snyder cut wound up being vastly,
vastly better than the Joss Whedon cut of Justice
League.
Rebel Moon. Part two is coming out in April 2024.
I do not know when they're going to release
those director's cuts
or if they're going to release like a single director's
cut for part one and part two.
Just jamming it together.
Kind of like Quentin Tarantino's Hateful Eight,
where they release like a bunch
of different episodes and it wound up
being like an eight hour long cut of the movie.
but at some point there will be super long versions
of all these Rebel Moon movies available
the first movie ends in a pretty abrupt cliffhanger
because we know that there was going to be a part
to their Seven Samurai space team basically comes back,
developed, thinking that everything is fine.
Like Admiral Noble, he's definitely dead.
They're definitely not coming back,
which of course they are.
you see it all over this trailer
they're couple of characters that they barely tease
like you barely see Balisarius is
there are a couple flashbacks with him
and then him in present day
They're couple scenes on Mother World.
They're like a couple flashbacks to the original royal
family before they were assassinated.
But it sounds like they're saving
a lot of that backstory for part two.
this trailer for Rebel Moon Part two also has a bunch
more flashbacks for the other characters, too.
So it seems like
we will be getting a bunch more backstory across.
Part two.
but essentially it seems like
just based on the trailer, that part two is mostly
dedicated to the actual fight,
like the other half of the Seven Samurai film
where they basically teach the townspeople
how to fight the armies of Mother World.
Come back
like Admiral Noble comes back with his Dreadnought.
They battle it out.
But there's a bunch of flashback scenes in there.
A bunch of scenes on Mother World, too, in the trailer.
So I'll try to put those into context
as we go through the video.
this person unfurling their cloak
might be on a completely different world in the middle
of some other completely different battle.
they're a bunch of different battles in the trailer,
some for different characters,
some on different planets.
this seems like the war robot Jimmy
But his lights are all red, so it might be
a flashback for him before they lay down their arms,
so to speak, In declared pacifism
the way that Anthony Hopkins character Jimmy explained
it is that he was created like his entire models line
were created to protect the unborn Princess Issa in lost
all their purpose when she was assassinated.
so essentially they still have all these battle skills,
but they refuse to use them
and they're now using them inside
the empire as worker robots.
they kind of got into that during part one
where all the troopers were trying to assault
that girl that Kora saved.
He yelled at Jimmy to kill Kora, but
Jimmy wouldn't do it even though he picked the gun up
is because all the robots within his model like him,
swore off all fighting when they lost their purpose.
When the princess was assassinated
which they kind of blame on Kora
like they don't explicitly say it,
but they call her the scar.
Give her quote unquote,
which is the title for part two.
Like part two is called Rebel Moon Score Giver,
which is the name that they sound
like they gave Kora
after the royal family was assassinated.
she kind of explained that back story
with Balisarius too.
Like Balisarius assaulted her world when he was
younger, then took her in like saw something in her.
But it looks like what he did
is he actually set her up as a sort of backdoor
to assassinate the royal family.
It made it seem like she did it herself,
like he groomed her gaslit her
till she was close to the royal family, then somehow
found a way to assassinate them and pin it on her.
Then he seizes power.
So if we're saying that Rebel Moon
is kind of a riff on Star Wars, like Zack
Snyder's alternate Star Wars
pitch that turned into something completely different,
then he'd be kind of like Emperor Palpatine
seizing power from the Senate during the prequels.
I don't know if he has any crazy force powers.
But we did see that Princess Isa
seems like she does actually have some powers.
So a version of the force
might actually exist inside the Rebel Moon universe
If Zack Snyder was going to be doing a Star Wars movie,
then the force would have existed during that
throughout the first movie and even in this trailer
to like part two, whatever future spinoff movies
or anything like that, you can see a lot of the analogs
for things that he changed to be copyright safe,
like Nemesis uses light sabers,
but they're kind of like plasma weapons
that look like lightsabers drippy looking lightsabers.
Lucasfilm.
Please don't sue us.
This next scene just seems like Admiral Nobles dread
not just moving through space
on their way back to belt.
we see General Titus
getting ready to address the townspeople.
Like I said, this is like
the other half of the Seven Samurai movie with them
arming up the village, teaching them how to fight
we get the voiceover from Kora
talking to the townspeople,
talking about how the mother world is deathly afraid
of the other worlds in the universe
rebelling against them.
They're afraid of us, like all the regular people
out there turning against them.
that's part of why one of the first things
that Balisarius did when he seized power was to try
and stamp out any form of rebellion so that it wouldn't
spread and become a much bigger thing.
there's a brief slo mo montage.
We're talking about Zack Snyder here.
So it wouldn't be Zack Snyder
if there wasn't a bunch of slo mo in his movies.
basically in the middle of their pitched ground assault
this is the dread not arriving back at village.
This is like that giant red planet that you saw
at the beginning of the first movie right next to belt.
robot Jimmy basically telling Kora
to take the lead on this.
There's no way you can win.
what they might do during
the course of the movie is part of Jimmy's arc
is he might find a reason to fight again
like he's in pacifism mode now
since Princess Isa was assassinated
if he doesn't know already, he'll probably learned
that Kora was involved in her assassination,
even if she didn't do it herself.
but I think we're building up to the moment
where a robot Jimmy also picks up
arms and finds a reason
to fight against the empire with them.
this is just another scene from that inner chamber
on Admiral Nobles
Dreadnought of him being shocked in that pool of fluid.
Not totally sure exactly how it works.
They're like,
what fluid are they pumping into him and out of him?
Most of his body seems like it's cybernetic.
He's meant to be kind of like the Darth Vader
in this Star Wars equation.
like a more space Nazi version of Darth Vader.
looks like they use this to resuscitate him,
keep him alive because he was on the edge of death
at the end of the last movie.
He hadn't completely died yet,
but they also use it for those space
Zoom calls like celestial Zoom calls, where
where he's talking to the region.
Bellisario is in that 3D space.
this is basically meant to be their version of Darth
Vader getting his armor put on
There's a much longer montage of all the villagers
arming up and General Titus
basically telling them to grab anything
that could possibly be used as a weapon.
there a couple of scenes of the main characters
like Tariq is helping them sharpen all the blades,
this was Dan.
He was supposed to be the best hunter in the village.
They cut his scene with General Titus, talking about
grabbing every hunting knife, every blade.
He's cocking the rifle, though, like he's
meant to be a crack shot,
there's a little montage of all the women
practicing with their blades on all the straw dummies.
Nemesis is supposed to be one of the deadliest blades
in the known universe.
Corey seems a little hopeful,
like they might actually have a chance.
this was that water girl.
The chorus from the other world
troops earlier in the first movie
just showing that she can shoot like,
she's a crack shot.
then we get Admiral Noble's Dreadnought entering orbit
and starting to land all their larger forces,
like all their troops, all their heavy infantry gear,
all their large siege weapons, a bunch of ships.
this seems like a flashback for General Titus,
this character to that battle
that he keeps referring to that
caused him to go a wall, desert the army, basically
it seems like all these people wound up
getting massacred, like some big shot from orbit
comes and destroys them all.
And that's the thing that broke him.
not sure who it is here.
This jumping off the building, killing themselves.
But look in the background, though,
this seems like it's happening on Mother World
and these towers are being destroyed
by this dreadnought.
This going kamikaze on them.
It might be Admiral Nobles. Dreadnought.
So this might actually be
after the final battle on Velt.
They might wind up winning.
The rebels might wind up getting Admiral Nobles
dreadnought and using it against Mother World.
this might be a nemesis flashback just to show more of
her origin story, like how she became the way she is.
This arm belongs to her.
You see it in this scene here
where she's using her twin light sabers.
then we get a much bigger montage of different scenes
of people fighting across that big battle on belt.
this scene.
Seems like Kora in the flashbacks
because she still has the short hair.
Not sure what the fire is behind her here.
This might be like right before she deserted
the army are a couple of scenes of the rebels
helping them on belts.
Like I said, it does seem like
they do show up during that battle to help them.
this scene is of Nemesis inside their main town
hall when they're training to get ready
to fight the other world.
there's a couple of different scenes of the characters
like Terek walking through the battlefield here.
All the ships fighting in the air,
bunch of aerial battles.
then it actually looks like Kora is attacking
someone on one of the mother world ships.
And it seems like they give her a blue light saber.
copyright, save, lightsaber.
like I said, part two is coming in April.
They'll probably release a much bigger trailer
pretty soon.
So of course
I'll do whatever videos they wind up releasing.
but if you have any big questions about what's going on
with the characters or just the lore
or the mythology just in general,
just write them below in the comments.
I just did my Aquaman 2 Post-Credits scene video.
It is the end of the DCEU to talk about Zack Snyder.
Like big coincidence.
It's like the last remaining DCEU movie of what
he helped create with Man of Steel in 2013 ten year
run, click here to watch that and click here for that
Henry Cavill Warhammer Trailer Video and Easter Eggs.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!